nathalie st-pierre et présidente de
l'association canadienne du propane
bonsoir madame clavières quand on dit
l'association canadienne du propane ou
vous représentez qui exactement
alors les gens qui font la production du
propane qui font la distribution en
incluant aussi les détaillants et les
manufacturiers de pièces également est
ce que vous appelez ça une crise parce
que ce que l'industrie l'association vit
présentement va manifestement je pense
que du point de vue des gens qui
utilisent le propane c'est une crise
alors effectivement je pense qu'on peut
que constater que ya un problème la main
j'ai un problème majeur parce que on
arrive au bout des réserves est ce qu'on
est capable de savoir combien on notre
propre réseau en fait on entendu le
ministre parlait de quelques 20 millions
de lettres je peux vous dire que hier
aujourd'hui et demain il y aura une
dizaine de wagons de chemin de fer qui
étaient prêts des entreprises qui font
normalement la distribution du propane
qui ont été donc amenés dans les lieux
pour le faire opérer le transfert du
propane vers des camions alors ça va
amener puisse être présent mais libre
par wagon donc on considère comme le
ministre par les 2.5 millions par jour
de donc sans meliet ces pauvres en même
ce qui est suffisant ils sont les deux
wagons soit cent mille c'est un million
de litres supplémentaires mais c'est pas
sexy une goutte d'eau dans
les besoins effectivement et la part du
propane transportés par train quelle est
la part du secteur ferroviaire dans le
transport de pop 1 en fait
au global mans au canada ce à peu près
60 3% évidemment pour l'export puisqu'on
exporter 50 % du propre ans et 80% du
propane qui passe par le rail et pour le
québec c'est 85% du propane qui arrive
pareil pareil par le par le canadien
national
ben à 85% du 85 par canadien national et
le reste par ses pci 6 donc est-ce qu'on
pourrait aller davantage côté de ces pcx
de ce modèle
eh bien vous savez il faut comprendre
comment ça fonctionne les rails chacun a
ses rails alors c'est très complexe et
on ne peut pas passer sur les rails de
l'autre ces pays peut pas aller à sarnia
qui la place de du séisme dont on ne
peut pas aller chercher du propane là
bas donc ce sont des règles qui sont
très complexes donc ses limites est en
quelque sorte est ce que d'autres moyens
de transport pour le profane exactement
le camionnage et donc en ce moment à
sarnia qui est le point le plus proche
parce que le reste du propane qui vient
à sarnia et livré par pipeline
à ce moment là en ce moment ici c'est ça
cette heure là certains quais de
chargement d'attentes pour les camions
comme le dit le premier ministre qui
n'est en alberta si on avait un pipeline
de ce qu'on aurait donc pas de problème
de livraison pop avait coûté encore là
il faut tempérer un peu effectivement
c'est sûr qu'on aura un accès beaucoup
plus direct et que l'eau avec le
camionnage on pourrait redistribuer
mais les ontariens qui ont un pipeline
enseignants connaissent en ce moment
mais évidemment la pression vient du
québec vient des états unis mais ils ont
effectivement eu aussi des problèmes
parce que à sarnia le problème était
redistribuée par tous par train aussi
par cm alors on constate que c'est pas
toujours si simple alors on voit bien la
ligne jaune ferroviaire là qui descend
jusqu'à toronto et donc la ligne bleue
qui descend c'est ça jusqu'à toronto la
pression à sarnia ici juste en bottes
toronto avec la ligne qui s'en va jusqu
au québec donc c'est s'est rendu à
toronto finalement qu'on peut pas aller
jusqu'au québec se sont rendus à sarnia
bella fallait un camion
à partir de sarnia sinon c était en rail
et donc est directement démenti par rail
ou par sarnia bon comment se fait-il
qu'on est au plus de provisions plus de
réserves pourquoi on n'a pas des
réserves pour plusieurs semaines de
probables mais on a des réserves quand
même substance hier on a des pros panier
au québec qui ont des installations qui
peuvent amener plusieurs voitures wagon
donc deux cent mille litres et mais
évidemment l'approvisionnement les
achats sont conclus pour la production
donc sont conclus par mois vous allez me
livre étant de centaines de milliers de
livres 1,2 million de litres et là
évidemment tout cela est prévu préparer
parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait de la place
au cn pour pouvoir livrer ça donc c'est
un enchaînement c'est vraiment un effet
domino et donc il faut conclure les
contrats s'assurer que ces sommes ne
soit sur les rails
que se soit livré que vous puissiez des
charges et là il ya plusieurs
entreprises vous les avez vu on les a vu
les images ils ont d énormes bon et 90
mille litres de stores âgées en ont
plusieurs
sur leur propre terrain et à partir de
ça normalement il revend le problème
c'est que c'est un approvisionnement
constant
mais là on n'a pas des autrement dit on
ne pas des semaines de résultats non et
des jours de réserve mais pas disent
même des noms et les maritimes sont dans
la même situation
moncton a plus de propane il ya des
réserves dans certains endroits pour
trois jours on parle aussi de l'île du
prince édouard et on a vu aussi le
premier ménez et l'île-du-prince-édouard
ont lancé le même signal que les autres
qu'il faut qu'une négociation il faut
que ça se résoudre quand les ting stress
dit ont créé une crise parce qu'on
laisse passer plus de pétrole
présentement on n'a pas ce que il ya pas
beaucoup de wagons qui circulait ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça écoutez je
sais pas combien de wagons qui circulait
ce moment si je sais que nous sommes en
discussion constante avec les cm pour
nous assurer qu'ils aient des livraisons
de propane je vous dirais que ça
pourrait aller mieux
effectivement donc est ce que on aller
coûte qu'on devra avoir pour puisque le
produit est vraiment essentiel à cette
époque si je pense qu'il y aura des
leçons à tirer de soap
la suite est ce que voulait dire par le
ministre des transports n'entend port ou
la ministre du travail n'entend pas
assez bien ce que vous dites je pense
que le gouvernement laisse aux parties
le soin de négocier
elle n'impose pas de loi spéciale ou de
loi spéciale
on comprend que ça va prendre ce teint
la mémé ou le cn de notre point de vue
je pense pas qu'ils avaient réalisé
l'importance que pouvait jouer le
probable bien qu'on ait communiquer avec
eux avant la crise bien avant quand on a
entendu parler de la grève
on s'est déjà mis en contact avec le cn
et on pourrait avoir de meilleures d une
collaboration pour faire en sorte que le
propane par des demandes là pour venir
au québec et dans les maritimes
meilleure collaboration du canadien
national
oui bon ok madame st-pierre on suit ça
de près parce que ça préoccupe beaucoup
de gens présentement merci merci merci
beaucoup